Hi, I'm Erica Clark, Food Editor for Parents Magazine.
I'm gonna show you how to make adorable, edible snow globes out of chocolate sandwich cookies.
All you need is a White Fudge Covered Oreo, a Grasshopper Fudge Mint Cookie,...
...vanilla Candy Melts and assorted cookie icy decorations such as sprinkles and edible glitter.
You can also use food-safe markers if you'd like to draw on your snow globe.
Spoon on some warm Candy Melts, sprinkle the sugar to form a snowbank,...
...and perch the penguin on top of it.
Once you've finished decorating your Oreo,...
...you can use Candy Melt to attach it to the mint cookie.
The Oreo will be vertical and the cookie will be horizontal,...
...so it looks like a real snow globe.
And there you have it, a snack-worthy snow globe.